vous venez de profférer des accusations
qui sont abjectes vous salissez chaque
jour un peu plus la politique à la
nupesse alors on s'attendait vraiment à
tout mais chaque jour un peu plus vous
permettez des choses qui ne sont pas
dignes dignes des Français qui nous
regardent
[Musique]
aujourd'huién vous parlez des violences
faites aux femmes les violences faites
aux femmes on est nombreux et nombreuses
ici à les dénoncer partout à se battre
dans nos rangs pour qu'elles en sortent
à même demander des sanctions pour
qu'ici dans nos assemblées elle cessent
et qu'il y ait des sanctions contre en
revanche au rassemblement national elles
sont nombreuses les affaires sur des
pédophiles et des violeurs qui n'ont
jamais été pris en compte donc avant de
faire la leçon aux autres avant de faire
vous voulez que je donne les noms parce
que ce sont des élus non non non ces
affaires sont publiques et en fait et en
fait vous plaît vous laissez per madame
regol merci et en fait quand on donne
des leçons on essaie à minima d'être
propre chez vous c'est la saleté qui
prédomine et en particulier sur les
violen faites aux femmes et c'est
scandaleux d'instrumentaliser les choses
ainsi quand vous avez des personnes dans
vos rangs condamné que vous n'avez
jamais jamais ça suffit le BO vous
répondrez ensuite
permettez-moi de vous faire part de
notre indignation vis-à-vis des propos
que nous faisons que nous venons
d'entendre on a quand même une collègue
dans cette salle de commission qui vient
accuser le rassemblement national de
fait absolument abject mais ce que nous
soulignons par ailleurs c'est qu'elle
manque de courage puisque quand nous lui
demandons de nous donner les noms et
bien là il y a plus personne donc
monsieur le Président nous sommes
particulièrement surpris de la tournure
que prend cette commission même si enfin
je je pense vraiment que de l'anupass on
pouvait s'attendre à tout mais là je
pense vraiment que ça dépasse les bornes